how does it feel to put out new music
after seven years
yeah it is uh it is a little bit of time
but uh really exciting i mean fantastic
especially uh especially during this
this time and
the coronavirus and everything i think
it's kind of exciting to have something
out and there's something about
entertaining people and i don't know i
think what we've done is i've enjoyed
what we did so
yeah so it feels good
what are you excited for your fans to
hear when it comes to the roadside
well um
yeah i mean and we try to make a kind of
an eclectic ep that's not just a one one
note you know so we each song is a
little bit different uh
but uh not that you haven't heard
everything but some things nod backwards
and some things look forward you know
but uh
yeah we used sort of all the influences
we could and uh had fun with them you
know really so we're all over the map a
little bit
but that's the fun of billy idol
yeah that's what's awesome about you and
your music now did you find you were
really creative over the past year and a
half how long have you been working on
this new music
well it's really just last last year
in may june we would we were starting to
work on this on this the cp
and uh
you know initially um
initially yeah we were just uh
we just happened to be writing stuff
just as the pandemic began and
i didn't want to write a song
straight off about the pandemic because
it was all so new you know we just
didn't really know where it's going i
mean i could see how it's affecting
everybody
quite radically i had a couple of
friends who were quite young and it was
it made them very sick and stuff so
but at the same time i didn't want to
try and write a song about the pandemic
immediately so
i thought what can i write about that
was kind of a watershed time in my life
where i knew things might change after
it where it was a problem i had to
overcome something dramatic and massive
and something that could you could have
altered my life forever and that was my
motorcycle accident i had about 30 years
ago where i nearly lost my leg they just
they saved it
and
everything i recovered okay but yeah i
just thought about this time when i went
through a particularly difficult time
when i had to face up to a lot of things
about myself
and put them right
and
so i thought well maybe if i write about
something like that or something huge in
my life that would sort of resonate with
people who were going through the plan
and not be directly about it
yeah no i completely understand that
very fascinating you know when i talk to
a lot of musicians a lot of people
really have to um
sit with themselves
really understand what makes them happy
you know change things in their lives so
it's interesting that this has been such
a reflective time for people
yeah that's right i think in a way
that's what it did made you think back
you know and and to go forward really
but
also uh
my daughter was kind of giving birth to
uh my grandchild uh
so uh so that was a beautiful thing to
be going on
kind of the balanced off the pandemic
and
and then we kind of wrote the song rita
hayworth that was kind of uh
it's a little bit in support of me too
and time's up it really was supporting
because i was thinking about you know
that my grandchild and my
my daughter's actually now pregnant with
another baby
oh congratulations
poppy rebel and possibly mary jane and
let me know in the future for them and
would i want the abuse they might face
and i just i was glad that things are
happening in society that's all
addressing the balance
making it safer for women i hope and
make it more of a equal playing field so
that their future is uh
will be sort of so much better and uh so
rita hayworth is a little bit of a song
sort of about that it's a fun song
though it's it's a fun song
how much do you love being a granddad
it's a lot of fun i really am enjoying
it i mean um
it's great being the you know granddad
you're not really disciplining them so
much or anything like that
really just being with them you know to
sort of
help them along and and
i just really do whatever she wants to
do you know that's
fun because i just do
just get into her world and
it's lovely and it was just what a great
thing to have going on when the pandemic
was going on because it was all so
positive and lovely and my daughter's so
happy
my daughter bonnie is just so happy
i love that
graham and she's got 10 000 followers so
she's like yeah she's already had a
people
people magazine so she's uh she's
already rocking
no big deal i love that now did i read
that she's actually a fan of some of
your greatest hits
well yeah she likes edm the most i think
called our baby shark at the moment you
know
but uh
yeah but yeah she she likes uh she rocks
out tonight she looks there was there
was a remix of seven nation army the you
know yeah white stripes she she's
rocking out in the bath to that she's
moving her hips and
she's making some of my faces i was
going i know those faces yeah
she's just bored
a lot of
her actions you know
they weren't prompted by seeing someone
else they weren't learnt they're just
yeah they're they're there innately so
tapping your toe
kind of rocking to the rhythm it's all
it's all there innately and it was
exciting to see that i don't remember
that with my own children so it was
kind of really exciting to see
yeah her just so excited by music and
and uh yeah of course we played some
billy idle stuff and she yeah i've got
the bar breaks of course she loves steve
stevens i might have guessed
of course
i love when you talk about her you just
you just glow it's so it's so lovely to
see um is it wild for you when you think
back
that next year is going to be 40 years
since you released your self titled
debut album is that is that wild does it
feel like 40 years ago
yeah well it's yes i mean it's kind of
crazy i think it's that long but uh
kind of for me it's fantastic to think
that i've been doing the thing i loved
all this time and enjoying it and still
doing it still having fun and still
you know putting out some great music
and
if if if i could still keep doing that
then the 40 years doesn't seem that long
it's like wow it's gone by in a flash
and
it's all been rather rather incredible i
mean it's been like a dream really or
something like you know something
incredible you could never have imagined
because you know initially when we
started out we i was in a punk rock
group in the mid 70s and like
we just thought that was going to last
for six months maybe a year maybe two
years at the most and then think we're
still here
you know 40 plus years later it's just
nuts you know it's your fantasy i love
that i love that so much you know when
you think back on that album and had
iconic songs an iconic album white
wedding uh dancing with myself hot in
the city what's your relationship with
those songs now do you still enjoy
performing those songs
yeah they've got if they've got a
certain
white wedding in particular has a
certain resonance it just does and
never gets old really it's amazing
rebel yells like that
a lot of them are like that a lot of the
best billy idol songs they just don't
get that old flesh for fantasy or
and then it's great to add this new
stuff um and i've got a feeling these
new songs
they won't get old they've got that
they've got something classic about them
and
so the idea that you're adding to what
your body of work is that's that's a
fantastic thing
yeah oh i can only imagine do you get
nervous about what critics are going to
say about your new music like did you
even care about that stuff
uh well of course i do i do wonder what
they're going to say and
like for instance the last album
we put out a few years ago kings and
queens the underground it got like a it
was my masterpiece in one magazine and i
got one out of ten in another magazine
there you go of course
you have to sort of go
you have to take it with a pinch of salt
that's really just like okay i get what
they're saying but not take it too
seriously as well otherwise you'll never
you'll fold you know you'll give up
it will take you down just hold on and
and just keep going
yeah is there a specific song that you
did not think would be a hit that became
a huge hit any songs that became so
popular that you were surprised about
well um
i suppose funnily enough dancing with
myself initially in england wasn't a hit
you know it got we put it out and it
only got to number 60 or something and
then yeah we sort of put it on my
american album and uh
what it ended up being was like a hit
video and it was it was like a hit in
the dance chart i watched it have this
life
and then last year tom hanks made it his
pandemic anthem so you know in a way
it's it's wild watching these songs have
a life you know that you couldn't
imagine you know and you don't you know
you're trying to write a hit song but
then but then you watch it make its way
and then in a way dancing myself yeah it
is a hit song it just uh
it's it's but it's been a hit video a
hit it's been a pandemic anthem it's
like wow they sort of they take on this
these these multifarious lives of their
own and that it's great to see people
using them in their everyday life that's
the thing that's most exciting is see
people
digging the song and using it you know
one way or another you know what however
they use it it's it's that's what's
exciting how people come to terms with
it and enjoy it that's great yeah
and i think that must be so rewarding
for you i mean your music is timeless it
doesn't matter when it came out people
still love it today people you know
loved it then like it's just that's so
rare
yeah i mean i'm just glad that the
music's had lasting impact you know
because that's another thing that you
wished for but you couldn't be sure that
was going to happen but
it's fantastic that you know would
manage to pull that off because uh yeah
that's the people if you can do that
and uh yeah and then the songs have got
to have got a lasting ability they can
still have an impact on people
oh that's funny absolutely um you know
you've obviously been in this industry
for a time you've seen highs you've seen
lows i'm sure with other musicians with
yourself as well
if you what advice do you have for a
young artist who is looking to follow in
your footsteps
well the thing is i think it helps if
you're doing it because you love what
you're doing i think that really helped
so that helps you to go through the
tough times because there are tough
times it doesn't like doesn't go in a
straight line and
you know success ebbs and flows and
justice thank god it does in a way
because that helps you to come you know
come to terms with things and think
again and come up with something new and
something that
extends your life extends your sort of
career and things
but that's it i think if you come from
the place of doing it because you love
it that'll help you get through the
tough times as well as the good times
yeah that's actually really good advice
i don't think people think about you
know the tough times you go through they
think of like the the fame and they're
like i want that but yeah you got to
love it yeah there's a load of down
times too and uh yeah that's when that's
when you know yeah that thing you reason
you do it comes into play
and
we're doing it for anything else but the
love
you could easily
drop off and
not want to do it anymore but if you're
there for the love then you kind of hang
on
i love that you know when you look at a
young artist today you think of the
weekend justin bieber shawn mendes what
do you think those guys are doing right
well i think they really do love what
they're doing uh and they're they're
because they're naturally gifted too i
mean justin bieber can really sing he's
got a great voice and
yeah the weekend is really telling super
talented and
it's just fun watching them have an
exciting time here watching them
you know negotiate their way through
quite a changing musical landscape
that's what's going on but there you go
new artists come along they find their
way through and
it's just exciting to see people
enjoying themselves and having success
and it's just it's much exciting for me
to see
these artists as it was to see the old
artists in the old days it really is and
it's just great to see people
and come up with new things and finding
new ways to be exciting you know
yeah you know at this point in your life
what would you say you prioritize most
what's important to you
well uh
obviously uh
i mean yeah my health and everything but
yeah really yeah it's great being a
granddad i'm you know it's uh
i'm enjoying that really uh
it's a big big part of my life now and
uh
yeah i'm just looking forward to uh my
relationship with the two children on
i'm i've got one i've got one at the
moment my daughter's just about to have
another baby girl so uh
i'll have two granddaughters so it's
kind of excited about
seeing where that all goes you know
it's so nice and you have the time to
enjoy
you know quality time with them too
which is lovely
that's right
yes so listen i need to geek out with
you for two seconds i love the wedding
singer so much it's one of my favorite
films of all time you are so good in
that movie do people come up and want to
talk to you about your cameo
yeah they usually do the some lines from
it or
a lot of people that young people
recognize me from the wedding singer
more than from
mtv or something so uh so thank god i
did it you know initially um i was
taking my son my when my son was young i
was taking the happy gilmore
adams films because they were you could
kind of take you know and
so when i got read the script for the
wedding singer and it was cracking me up
right from the start but i thought this
is fantastic because i could be in the
film i'm going to take my son to and
then because
he i took my son willem to the set and
with a friend of his
and then it was near halloween so uh
adam had all this candy and stuff in his
trailer and he just he piled them up
with like they had a pile of candy you
know so and the director let that my son
sit next to him when he shot the
you know so they could see how it all
worked and if they were like 10 years
older
so it was very exciting and a lot of fun
and
then of course
went to the premiere and everything and
it was just it was great to be in it
it's just a fun really fun movie
ah you're the cool dad for sure
i was cupid i put the lovers together in
the end you know
exactly
i was playing
that movie is nothing without you let me
tell you um what a pleasure getting to
talk to you you're
you're so lovely i'm so excited for
where you know your grandkids and and
your new music what an exciting time for
you
thank you morgan it's been fun talking
to you too